I'm delighted to be joined by mr. Paul
Collins from rare great shirt you guys
should sell those people have pick them
up on a few more shirts to give out the
swag swag man yo come out via the
internet to everyone out there great to
see you guys back in forum man great
yeah it's been an awesome e3 for us the
one-two punch of celebrating the old and
also like up the stages with cfpb's for
sure so later this year we're gonna get
thirty rare games yep for $30 yeah
August 4th we're gonna have rare games
spending six console generations there's
games like jet pack an amazing offering
in terms of things like jet force Gemini
on blast core the original conquer for
the end at the n64 we also got ki gold
in there too all the way up to the
xbox360 titles like cameo nuts-and-bolts
it's an amazing collection it's my
absolutely jam-packed with extra Kajol
who's doing nuts and balls we were
talking about it beforehand perhaps the
best banjo kazooie game I absolutely
love it but I got some friends who love
the old ones as well so do you have all
the banjo so we've got the the xbox live
remakes of banjo kazooie and banjo tooie
and also perfect dark in there cool it's
been awesome having there the back
compact so we've been able to have the
nine xbox 360 titles in the collection
ice awesome yeah a bit of Battletoads in
there as well got our C program and
amazing set of games there from the
older generation it's funny like when
you first
we've been have a lot of people coming
up to play them and as they go through
the game list yes all the games in there
they're like a standard like I didn't
realize you guys made slalom Koba
triangle Battletoads of course has been
awesome to and grabbed by the Ghoulies
amazing - for the Xbox one
of course you've got the infamous
Battletoads in there too and we've got
great offering in terms of the the nez
version of battletoads we've said the
arcade version which for some people
they might not have got the first the
attack the chance to play the first time
around so you can also play it free
player which is a very cool brawler
it's interesting is that you put 30
games on a disc and then the first thing
people say is where all the other ones
around here like games that aren't there
at Goldeneye for instance you guys do
you guys even on the rights to that so
for every play it's always been about
celebrating the games that you need to
rare games that the rare world's rare
characters a gameplay that only rare can
do and so when we kind of put the
collection together we wanted to wheel
it down to the games that really best
point to the
stuff that we've created and so it that
this collection is just full of games
that only rare could make and one of the
awesome things too is over the 30 years
it's not just been 30 years of
first-person shooters
we've gone the whole spectrum of
different types of games and experiences
we've got blood formers puzzles and
sometimes we just break boundaries with
like things like Viva Pinata we'll just
go for a life sim it's a fun time even
pinata as well the pinata and trouble in
paradise
great right so I can completely struggle
to get candy animals to have sex all
over again on in that drug inertia so
yeah what's it like for you guys working
you've been there for six years yes yes
like in the six years you've been there
rare is kind of in the connect studio so
it's a bit of a big turn for you guys
that I couldn't dive way back into your
into your history well the really cool
thing is that for us as a studio like I
mentioned we never wanted to stick to
just one type of genre so Kinect Sports
was showing again how we can do sports
games like back when we were made games
for Nintendo like John Elway Madden so
it's we're not shy of any type of genre
and one of the things I love about
working at rare is that the next project
could be something completely different
you never know what the next turn is and
that's one of the things that really
excites me at the studio so what is the
next term for you guys it's like you
know you bring in 30 games this is
obviously something guys been working on
for a while trying to get them all
working and what are we gonna see from
you guys is Kinect gone from from rare
now for us we're really focused on where
we play and making that as almost oh my
god so many people playing that and of
course we've got CFE so there's two
awesome projects on the go here which
were really excited about we think that
are really something there for the fans
and what was the reception like a rare
when ukulele was announced it was
awesome like those guys that are working
on that I really found memories of
working with them I got the chance to
work with Chris saw Gavin on Kinect
Sports so for all of us we're just so
happy for them and we can't wait to play
it it's also interesting as well that
there's 30 games coming out on this like
you know if you the average price for an
HD remake of something is you know in
the range of five to ten dollars yeah
why are you so nice adding up for 30
like it seems like the type of thing you
could probably get away with selling for
a fifty quid or six for us we've always
felt like wolfram from my perspective
I'd always loved it to be a no brainer
purchase we didn't want to get that
price point that made it feel like
should I buy this shouldn't I buy this
as many people as possible to pick up at
day one and even preorder it for us and
so in August 4th you get these 30 games
and at the time then it comes out August
4th it's the kind of that come out
sometimes a bit of a lull period whether
it's not that mini games coming out and
with the amount of content in some of
the collection it just was like a great
time to really get your hands back into
some of the games from rare that you may
have missed alongside the 30 games to
mention there's just so much content in
there we've also got what we're calling
our snapshot challenges okay and these
are bite-sized mini games that showcase
some of the the older classics in the
collection and they're just a nice segue
back into the games we've got our own
little spin on them whether it's like a
Battletoads turbo tunnel infinite well
we basically just make it keep going
round and round and see how long you can
survive in Battletoads that's been an
absolute gem on the the show floor for
us the engineer that was working on it
he got seven minutes he was managed to
stay in turbo tunnel for seven minutes
someone's come over and like over the
course of the week he's managed to
survive in it for 30 minutes so far so
it's been absolutely crazy
these are they also have leaderboards
attached to them as well so you can keep
on like trying your scores against your
friends and the community as well and
it's also incentivize players to check
out the whole collection
we've also added exclusive videos there
only especially for rare replay like
trailers and staff for a magazine
behind-the-scenes yes so we've made
documentaries when over the course of
the project we've made documentaries on
the making of banjo conker how dream
became banjo we've got a ki one in there
a bit of Battletoads of course we've
also got some showcases around some of
the games that were never released to
something called sundown which was a
safari horror game the work done so it's
just absolutely jam-packed it's so much
than just ferry games like I'm sure you
guys enjoyed working on the connect
Sports rivals and then and the games he
were making but surely like the vibe and
rare must be like you guys must be I'm
so much happier now that you're like
diving back into like this sort of
massive well of design that yeah we're
always really happy with whatever we
work on and I think just because we've
all like experienced a rare game I think
throughout that for all our childhoods I
think one of the rare games or ultimate
games has always been a part of your
child even if you didn't know rare made
it and I feel like the whole time we've
been working and everyone's just been
super excited to bring them together the
excuse to basically play all of these
games again at work it's just been
phenomenal like I really love blast core
it's one of my favorite games too and
going back to play through them again
and just how well they still whole
up to this day as well as great and like
I said everyone that's really lighting
up I'm so excited about specific games
and having them all in there like people
come up to the show floor and just being
completely astounded at some of the
games in the collection it's just been
such a great person yeah.well design
games are our timeless and another fun
thing about them that I saw up there was
10,000 game thousand game of school
great great spread across 30 games that
as my math work is that 300 piece
there's quite a bit in there so you've
got the with the back compare titles in
that they've got those achievements too
and we've also got the with the the main
replay part that's where they're the big
new grunt of achievements come from so
it's just this really is something for
everyone in the title smashing so the
the rare rare cut is just full rare
collection it's called rare replay rare
replay I had it down as on my sheet for
like the past two weeks says unannounced
microsoft collection I was like actually
yeah before you go how did you manage to
get this out without it being leaked
like I know Kotaku had something at the
end of last week I was felonio basically
mostly got it out it's so well then it
was funny I think just before the night
before the the show we stuck we were
just about to toast we didn't leak and I
think we must have put the mockers on
ourselves picked up my game stuff was
something it's just a narrative but the
great thing was that although the
collection got announced and what leaks
Robert they didn't really know what the
games are going to be in yes I did I did
go on to some foreign to see but
everyone was just so happy and I love
the speculation about what games are
going to be in the title and of course
they didn't know what extra content was
in the park illness and it's so worth
checking out the amount of work and
effort that's gone into there everyone
that's worked on the collection just
loves rare loves the rare game so we
really wanted this to be something that
celebrated the studio and also the fans
awesome pecans like you so much for
coming on best luck for you the team and
finishing it off and we can't wait to
dive into as if there wasn't enough good
games coming out in 2015 we got 30 more
lumped in so thanks to everyone over in
the UK that's like chief or watching on
YouTube on the e3 hub on GameSpot and of
course on hitbox we'll be back in a
second stay tuned on GameSpot